foreign
[Music]
inside
you'll see that idea
small deviations
[Music]
and then if I
go up
it's gonna he's not gonna do it
yeah not even your UK is going to do it
because they know I'm going to enter and
take their base out right and they don't
want to be found
okay so they're gonna sense it and
they're gonna resist it okay
so this is it over here shove it over
there like that in his job to hold on to
me
okay pay attention
to send deviation let him go by he'd
already passed me
and very relaxed
very relaxed
super relaxed
boom
oh
very relaxed he's going by me
Hazard accounts
keep his elbow Underneath Him
you see then when you let it out
it comes up this way comes up the way it
wants to go
don't check it like regular Taino henko
that's why you need the deviation
[Music]
you have to release
the pressure
in your heart don't let him trigger you
it's super soft
[Music]
super soft
not here
super soft same way as our noodles
[Music]
okay
let's try soften it up your hand is not
sideways to their head
it's not silent
it's going
he's pushing and I'm on top of it
and then behind it
now I'm not on the side making a side
Circle
I am going to go on top of his shirt
boom let him uh there his hands there
um
this way that's what I mean you don't
want his elbow in you don't want to
double it boom that was it
super relaxed and then when you get here
don't start jerking it out
use the center connection that you have
okay
don't pull out of it
don't
get it in place Center
let's say he he knows he's gonna go so
he let's go
that little Ike adhesion on the center
is enough
done
don't yank it out
still have a center in your hand okay
let's try just that arm again and then
your goal is to get the elbow up the
elbow has to be up okay just like you
were going to do Shiva
elbow has to be if the elbow's not up
he's got too much balance
so you have to get that elbow uh that's
how you can do the elbow so too that we
would if you had that elbow low then the
technique was like not making
uh
foreign
[Music]
don't start letting her trigger you just
keep it going up
turns out at the end did you see that
when we do the technique it won't be
able to right so I control your elbows
so you want to practice
the fall the right way instead of taking
pressure out okay okay you're going to
fall with your Center follow your hand
nope okay
no what you do is that little turn right
so see how your elbows out and when you
turn like that your elbow comes down so
if I was doing the throw out we'd never
let her elbow down you see and the two
throws you did no elbow down so you
don't put it down
the first beginner technique
don't go right away here
move keep it up move your body first
then it goes better you're going to lose
balance first okay
lose balance first
other other side
boom up lose balance first and then do
chemicals first then do a cameo lose
balance first and again
do you see
it didn't matter that he's taller his
elbow still has
foreign
has a yogic understanding to your body
geometry okay so before I go
[Music]
there's the energy coming from my
final line just to simplify it emanating
out
and it's not only on one side so that
this side is
my feet are solid
Christmas
both sides the LIE
foreign
energize let's go